a former nfl linebacker and unlv player  adam stewart could be taking a plea deal  in a hit and run case this is a story  the eight news now i-team first broke  the 38-year-old is charged with failing  to stop at the scene of a crash near  sahara and town center in march of 2021  police say he crashed into a pole badly  injuring a woman in the passenger seat  he later dropped her off at the hospital  she has since filed a lawsuit against  him and court records show he may be  pleading guilty to a felony charge of  neglect of safety of person or property  resulting in substantial bodily harm his  attorney asked for time to review the  plea deal